just read me reading me daddy oh I'm
gonna read you like a book
[Music]
hey guys we're here to play an
embarrassing edition of never have I
ever and I'm here with Joyce and he
drops men hey I'm really excited to like
get the hot tea on you guys I want
everything you have a big pot because
there's a lot of tea to be bored I'm so
glad I know you first question
never have I ever dropped my cell phone
on my face while I'm looking at it in
bed I was like yeah that's it yeah I
literally did that like five minutes ago
before I came in here I actually did
that like two nights ago shut myself to
sleep my husband came in at 5:00 in the
morning and he was laughing because the
lights were on the phone was on my chest
never have I ever sent a delivery driver
a kiss blowing emoji by mistake when
they text to say they're there oh really
yeah yeah I've done that oh I looked at
the photo so you did it on purpose I
miss you like lord have you ever hooked
up with your post mates guy okay what
makes are we talking about like like
anything oh yeah how many stars did you
get I mean I gave them a solid point
oh good person are we talking about you
or the make out there we stars after
evening out with him if you're gonna get
five from me you're gonna work for it
never have I ever realized I'm not a
toilet paper after I've already sat down
on the toilet what looks like one yeah
everyone's been there before it's how
you it's a real test of who you are as a
person it separates the men from the
boys and the women from the girls that's
like how do you improvise you got a
MacGyver in the situation oh man how do
you improvise when you don't have toilet
paper and your husband is in or out
depends if I'm in a public restroom I'll
like say hey ladies can you pass me over
some toilet paper or if I'm like in a
place where I'm alone
then I do a little swimming snakes I
wait a second and I do a little crawl
over and I go far my cells and good yeah
you got to do that you can or go right
into the shower
yeah that's an option all right you guys
ready for next one yeah when to throw
something out and saw that there's no
bag in the trash can
I mean come on that's my biggest pet
peeve but I've done it yeah but what do
you do in that situation what do you do
after
yeah I think that's a test of your
character do you go and get a trash bag
sometimes I do that or you just throw it
in there anyway and let it be someone
else's problem also I've done them well
I immediately go get a trash bag I don't
believe that but I love that things we
believe that you're great - never have I
ever sent a screenshot of a text
conversation to the person I had the
conversation with by mistake this is
like one of my hardest things are you
recitative people who when you're
reading something but you're thinking
about something else you write the word
that you're thinking of like do you ever
do that I do okay so if you do that then
you obviously send the screenshot at the
wrong person because it's so hard to
focus
you're in your head you're like oh I'm
talking about this person and you're
just propping their name and that's
gonna get hit yeah and the way you
recover is you kind of like make it be
like did you see what you just said here
sort of like oh are you in serious when
it's like I'm also roasting you behind
your back but you don't need to know
that part sketch so never have I ever
responded good and you after the other
person has already said good in you yeah
I've got all these things I've done that
yeah I would the thing is with this
though is I will always I do something
like this I'll get clocked about like
not paying attention like I'm a total I
don't like no I pay attention and just I
wasn't put like whatever you know no I
agree like sometimes if the conversation
is dry like I do it and I'm like okay
can you say something else I'm like
pretty dyslexic so I'm like saying like
what's up in a backwards way I'm putting
good in you in
the same question and I'm like what's
good you never have I ever waved to
someone who wasn't waving at me oh my
god seems like I remember time I was at
Walmart and I thought this like tall
like dude was my dad it's my dad's like
super tall and like whack right so
there's a super tall black guy watch
like it's any being attention to me
there's like my father your life about
and I walk up to him not my dad and then
my dad was like so just live would never
have ever said goodbye to someone and
then walked in the same direction as
done when I loved just for real the
worst date of my life
oh you know how you like avoid the kiss
like you like so this is the person this
is me and like kings like this and I'm
like so I'm like okay let me go cuz my
cars over there I forgot that he parked
over there too so we're just like I was
awkwardly like in front of him like
speed talking then I got on the phone
and I like call my best friend and I was
like yeah you know it's really hard I
don't you don't feel that bad
never have I ever called my boss or
teacher mom or dad by accident I have
not done that I have I also do it
intentionally why I like wait I don't
that's I don't but that's what you have
by mistake I like everyone's like mom
dad like that's like a term of
endearment now you know what I've never
like for your friends yeah so you're
gonna go to your boss and be like what a
boss but like teacher yeah like I said
oh we call on our teacher a master
teacher you said like if you called your
boss dad like I'm sorry that I thought
the HR completely boring the thing is my
boss like is my dad in some ways do you
know your boss I don't know
I mean I guess if you have like a super
nurturing relationship and it's like not
in a sexual way like okay
I love both my bosses and it's the type
of relationship where we text memes back
and forth like that sort of thing so you
guys are friends yeah we're friends so
it's like yeah I'm gonna call you mom
and dad see I always call people mom and
dad if they're like my friends mom or if
my friends get into relationships
because I've learned that all couples
treat single friends amazingly mm-hmm
yeah yeah and when you sleep over they
give you a blanket for the couch yeah
yeah and they both like watch over you
when you're going to sleep and eat
anything in the night the couple friends
will be right there for you yeah I
called them mom and dad right we have a
few singles in our life we call us mom
and dad yeah yeah I think we did well I
think you know all of us would be
friends I think we have a lot in common
yeah I mean we believe in the same
things and I don't know I wasn't
embarrassed I mean I wouldn't be
embarrassed like trip over something in
front of you guys I feel like you would
laugh and we'd all laugh together and be
fine don't we get guns they're all
embarrassing things but we don't feel
embarrassed yeah so pretty much you know
my homegirl got a book coming out she's
gonna let you know about it it's called
do what feels good and you guys should
all get it so I'm pre-order and it's out
January 8th and it's basically
everything you need to know to get your
body feeling right so that you can get
some love some self-love and be a better
person that's like perfect for January
in the air oh yeah ooh your new baby
yeah I know hoeing season is coming you
better get ready
you better drink that I'll reduce that
Hey come on go to the store
you
[Music]